the uncomfortable thing to talk about is
that a lot of times there's a way to fix
a dog or save a dog or something and and
a lot of people can't afford it which
just brings me to pet insurance guys get
your pet insurance
so you're a big advocate for that i mean
i
don't have it it's too i'm too far gone
i can't get it now but i could for a new
pet but from what i understand it's
really helpful for people i don't think
it's help it works for dental at all but
and there there are some packages that
are more comprehensive than others and
i'm yeah i'm surprised you brought it up
because i think that is the solution so
going back to the other you touched on
it the other major thing i have to deal
with
is
telling someone i can't treat your pet
because you don't have money so the
devastation on their eyes when they've
come in and it's just it's just an
accident when you get a dog or cat it's
not about if it's about when so you
paying that 30 dollars a month for your
pet insurance you know there will be a
two four thousand dollar bill whether
it's next week because there were cards
came by and you left the gate open or if
there's cancer in the future there's
just no some sort of cardiac disease
something is going to happen
you're going to need a prescription
you're going to need a whatever it is
and a lot of them include vaccine stuff
which i want to talk to you about in a
second um and uh there's no reason to
not get it just if you if you cannot
afford the 30 a month for the patients
just don't get a dog wait till you can
because that will change your life and
and
more times than i can count i've had to
tell somebody in that moment because i'm
not the practice owner maybe i'm an
associate and i have to tell that person
it comes out in a business decision i
more than i want to
this is what i can do i can alleviate
the suffering
and i can triage your pet
but
this broken femur that's going to cost 2
500
i just that i can't do and then what
happens is they blame me of course
you're you're gonna you're gonna let my
dog die of course you're gonna kill my
dog and that's and then i carry that
homework well see that that is totally
unfair and i understand being in grief
and needing someone to blame to feel
better but the the the vet is not the
person to do that too it drives me nuts
and it's like yelling at the flight
attendant because the plane's sitting on
the tarmac for 40 minutes like she has
no like this isn't her fault you know
you're just yelling at an innocent
person
who's already in pain about this you
know what i'm saying i'm already in a
situation where i have to deliver you
bad news and cannot save this patient
because as much as i want to but here's
the other thing i'm the bitch who will
go oh you have a twenty five hundred
dollar breeder dog but no health
insurance for this dog and then you're
gonna say you can't afford stop buying
dogs yeah how about that how about
rescue a dog
use some money to train it do whatever
you need to do and then get pet
insurance so when something bad happens
you actually can
pay for it yeah i just jumped on board
with a big pet insurance
company here called fetch and i i am a
huge advocate of retaining pet insurance
and the other thing is
um
not optional yeah right it is a
trickle-down effect then it's we spread
it out of course some people can use it
more than others but everybody gets the
care i don't have to be the bad guy yeah
yeah i mean there's a couple things also
it's like i i just think it's important
like and this is part of the reason
we're doing this podcast and i think we
should do it kind of regularly because i
guess for someone that spends so much
time in vet offices with veterinarians
like in the animal world like i'm like
oh i thought this was like common
knowledge i guess there's a lot of stuff
that people don't have time to know you
know or don't have time to learn and if
they don't they're just going to go on
the internet and get some answer that's
not true or some silly shit so that's
why i want to go through a couple things
that i think are like commonly
misunderstood
uh things and also um a couple like life
vet hack sort of
[Music]
one four things four four four
[Applause]